blm backs the communist cuban regime the
democrats seek to ram through amnesty by
attaching it to a budget bill and the
biden white house blows out the spending
amidst an inflationary spiral i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet
join them at expressvpn.com slash ben
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first
your reminder you're spending way too
much on your cell phone bill unless
you've already switched over
to pure talk usa thousands of my
listeners already have here's the thing
if with verizon or at t or t-mobile
you're paying too much money
pure talk can save your family over 800
a year
same great coverage because beer talk is
on the exact same network as one of the
big three
but at a fraction of the price and
switching is as easy as switching out
your sim card you can keep your phone
keep your number or get huge discounts
on the latest iphones and androids plus
right now you can get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and
if you go over on data they're not going
to charge you for it there's a reason
pure talk is the highest rated wireless
company by consumer affairs and why they
are the preferred wireless partner of
amac a lot of other cell phone companies
they will intentionally mislead you on
exactly what it is you are getting
they'll be
pretty obscure about what it is you're
paying for not so with pure talk usa
they're telling you exactly
what you get and it's what you need from
your cell phone dial pound 250 save ben
shapiro save an additional fifty percent
off your very first month that is pounds
two five zero say keyword ben shapiro to
get started again dial pound 250 say ben
shapiro save an additional 50
off your first month and hundreds of
bucks down the road alrighty so
cuba continues to be a hot spot the
cuban police have now been rounding
people up i mean to the point where
there's actual video of cubany youtube
stars
being picked up like they'll literally
be on the air doing spanish tv
and the cuban authorities will arrive
and literally just arrest them while
they are on the air for the great sin of
dissenting
from the communist authoritarian regime
over there here's a little bit of tape
this happened yesterday
this woman named dina stars she's
apparently some sort of youtube star
and the authorities are showing up to
arrest her
and she is now being taken away by the
cuban authorities
so good times over there um the the
cuban
crackdown is not unexpected this is what
has happened with regards to every
dissident movement
in cuba in latin america in central
america that is directed against a
communist
authoritarian regime obviously we saw
just a couple of years ago when millions
of people were in the streets in
venezuela and yet the venezuelan
communist regime
continued to maintain its power by
cracking down
on people who were dissenting now
meanwhile
i have to say that the left's
perspective on this is absolutely
astonishing the left
in america because for people who really
say that what they want is denmark or
norway they have a really tough time
simply condemning communism they have a
really rough time saying
that these regimes are evil and bad i
think bernie sanders a couple of days to
comment when he did comment
he read directly from the howard's in
playbook where he talked about how it
was really the united states embargo
that was the problem
in cuba and now you have black lives
matter sounding off
the movement now let me remind you black
lives matter is a semantically
overloaded term there are some people
who when they say black lives matter
mean the perfectly obvious thing which
is that black lives matter
just like every life matters and black
people should not be targeted by the
police
more than anybody else should be
targeted by the police right that's
perfectly obvious
but the black lives matter organization
which is ricked in tens of millions of
dollars
and fostered not just protests but riots
in cities
around the united states and is run by
open communists
they put out it's just a garbage
organization it's been a garbage
organization since it was it was founded
in in the mid 2010s and it's its
founders
are openly marxist in orientation
meanwhile skimming off the top
presumably or allegedly
in order to go buy themselves really
really nice houses in tobago canyon
so black lives matter the organization
which remember you had corporations
donating millions of dollars to yet
people posting black squares in support
of the organization
not just the generalized idea in favor
this organization is a garbage co a
garbage communist organization
so far when it comes to world issues
they have supported
the the hamas terrorists in the gaza war
and now they support the communist cuban
regime
and it is telling here is what they say
quote black lives matter condemns the us
federal government inhumane treatment of
cubans
now you may have noticed that the u.s
federal government does not actually run
cuba and they're not the people
arresting youtube stars
or shooting people in the streets black
lives matter
condemns the u.s federal government's
inhumane treatment of cubans and urges
it to immediately lift the economic
embargo
this cruel and inhumane policy
instituted with the explicit intention
of destabilizing the country
and undermining cubans right to choose
their own government is at the heart of
cuba's current crisis since 1962
the united states has forced pain and
suffering on the people of cuba by
cutting off food medicine and supplies
costing the tiny island nation an
estimated 130 billion dollars so you see
it's all the
fault of the united states amazing it's
all the fault of the united states
according to black lives matter because
according to black lives matter
the west is always wrong according to
the black lives matter organization
the organization that millions tens of
millions of americans marched with
last year this uh according to this
organization
america is a terrible place and is
responsible for all the world's elders
why would you trust them when it comes
to the cops
to the systems of power in the united
states why would you trust them with
regard to anything
they're a communist group period end of
story and here they are
repeating communist propaganda my
favorite part of this particular
paragraph
is where they say the united states has
been undermining cuba's right to choose
its own government
you know what really undermines cubans
rights issues their own government the
fact that they haven't held a vote since
1962.
they didn't in 1962 either okay so it's
been
six decades since the cuban revolution
and the uh and the communist regime
there has never allowed a free and fair
election
and black lives matter is saying the
united states is denying them the right
to choose their own government because
blm again is a garbage organization i
can't say it too many times
let me reiterate say it real slowly for
those of you who are having a tough time
black lives matter the organization is
garbage
should be condemned and no responsible
person should be associated with it
blm continues without that money it is
harder for cuba to acquire medical
equipment needed to develop its own
coven-19 vaccines and equipment for food
production
this comes in spite of the country's
strong medical care and history of
lending doctors and nurses to disasters
around the world
uh it wouldn't be complete statement
without a bit of propagandizing on
behalf of the cuban healthcare system
which by the way
is so lacking the cuban healthcare
system they couldn't get coven-19
vaccines into the arms of people in cuba
says blm the people of cuba are being
punished by the us government because
the country has maintained its
commitment to sovereignty and
self-determination
yes nothing says sovereignty and
self-determination quite like
throwing tens of thousands of people
over the years in prison forcing people
to float in jerry-rigged canoes
basically across
a hundred miles of shark-infested ocean
to get to florida
self-determine it sounds like
self-determination when you don't allow
anybody to vote ever it's it's it really
is
it's amazing levels of
self-determination here blm says
united states leaders have tried to
crush this revolution for decades
instead of international amity
respecting goodwill the us government
has only instigated suffering for the
country's 11 million people
of which four million are black and
brown uh there it is it's because the us
is racist of course because everything
comes down
to racism for black lives matter
remember the crossover
between the the racial reckoning that we
are having via groups like blm
and the full-on marxist agenda of many
of these groups
is very heavy indeed in the same way the
critical racial theory
is very much connected to the idea that
the institutions of capitalism and
individual rights have to be torn down
derek bell was very clear about this in
his own writings
says black lives matter cuba has
historically demonstrated solidarity
with oppressed people of african descent
okay if by that they mean that cuba has
shipped troops to places in africa to
help establish communist regimes there
and kill
black people in defense of those
communist regimes that would be correct
from protecting black revolutionaries
like assata shakur
through granting her asylum to
supporting black liberation struggles
in angola mozambique guinea-bissau and
south africa
unbelievable but totally believable now
we look to president biden to end the
embargo something barack obama called
for in 2016. this embargoes a blatant
human rights violation and it must come
to an end
now why bother reading the entire blm
statement because blm
the organization is not dissociated from
the
generalized democratic party they are
not the democratic party still refuses
to condemn blm as an organization
it's leaders still hobnob with blm
and it is not a coincidence that this
administration the bite administration
is having an extremely
tough time speaking moral words about
what is happening in cuba right now
for example shinsaki was asked yesterday
whether the biden administration would
put out a statement condemning communism
right now would seem a good time now the
bible administration has taken the
tactic
of attempting to minimize what is going
on in cuba they say that the current
cuban unrest
that the the massive protests in the
streets are not driven
by cuban communism per se instead they
are driven
by something else they are driven by
mismanagement
right it's the mismanagement that's the
problem if the communists were just good
managers then everything would be fine
but the communists are bad managers and
so it's a little bit bad but it has
nothing to do with communism
per se so here is gensake being asked
about condemning communism and
shying away from it do you think that
people are leaving cuba because they
don't like communism
i think we've been pretty clear that we
think people are leaving cuba or not
leaving cuba or protesting in the
streets all as well because
they are opposed to the oppression to
the mismanagement of the government
in the country and we certainly support
their rights of protests we support
their efforts to speak out against their
treatment in cuba
hmm i'm noticing a word missing there
oppression and mismanagement if it
weren't for the oppression mismanagement
communism
it's a beautiful idea she's never worked
in in practice
guys that's that's it true communism has
never been tried if only they could just
get
rid of the oppression and mismanagement
that would solve it and then she's asked
again
like so are you guys gonna put out a
statement condemning communism at any
point here
yeah well we hear from the president
this week he said the other day that he
would speak out on that and and secondly
is is his position still that he feels
that the trump
policies were a failure it didn't affect
change is that still his policy
well again i would say one in terms of
whether he heal from him he says that
often as you know and what he means is
he speaks out publicly nearly every day
at events sometimes you all ask
questions if there's an update to
provide on
what we're doing on what our policies
are certainly he'll provide that is
there a planned speech or trip
not at this time there's no planned
speech or trip again
it's amazing how hard a time the left
the squad even the mainstream democratic
party has
simply saying communism is evil and back
in the 1960s the democratic party didn't
have any problems saying communism was
evil
but then something turned and the sort
of
soft fellow traveler sensibility that
bernie sanders carries around with
regard to communist regimes has infused
large swaths of the democratic party and
it's quite awful and it's quite
disgusting and it demonstrates once
again
that domestically speaking the
people who believe in the basic tenets
of marxism which is that the united
states
is a class struggle which has never been
historically true in the united states
the united states is not about class in
the same way that europe was about class
that are not these
are sort of hard and fast classes from
which people can never move
but the the folks who purport to say
that this is what america is all about
they are they are completely unwilling
to condemn actual oppression by
communists
on a global scale and this does go back
to the cold war when the left in the
united states
played ftse with communist regimes
throughout the world and refused to
condemn them throughout the 70s and 80s
particularly
apparently not very much has changed
which is uh pretty shocking
by the way it is there is a reminder to
be had here
that barack obama and his administration
were quite friendly to the cuban regime
you'll recall that you traveled to cuba
but he hung out with raul castro he held
hands with the guy
he went to a baseball game with him and
then he prays the cuban dictator
it so nothing new under the sun
i said this to president castro in cuba
i said look you've made great progress
in educating
uh chil uh young people every child in
cuba
gets a basic education that's that's a
huge improvement from where it was
medical care
you know the the life expectancy of
cubans
is equivalent to the united states
despite it being a very poor country
because they have access to health care
that's a huge achievement
they should be congratulated oh well and
then amazing they should they should be
congratulated
the cubans for for you know having been
dominated by a communist regime for
quite a while why does the left have
such a
tough time with us why they have such a
tough time condemning an actual
communist dictatorship
i think the answer is fairly obvious
they have a lot of sympathy for the
ideas that undergird the communist
dictatorship
that would be the only rationale for why
they are having such a tough time with
this one
this is not a hard one forget about the
sort of policy
prescriptions here the moral statement
that communism is a great evil
should not be tough and yet for a lot of
folks apparently it really
really is i will say i think my favorite
media take on this over the last couple
of days there's a take
from reuters here is the the headline
quote cuban protests risk exacerbating a
covet 19 spike
so we are now back to the 2020 headlines
where and if you gather to protest
lottie and you're going to spread covet
but
if you gathered to dance in defense of
george floyd
then you're definitely not going to
spread covet all i can say is communism
is a public health crisis
just like racism supposedly a public
health crisis communism in cuba is much
more of a public health crisis than
racism in the united states has been for
quite
a long time alrighty in just one second
we'll get to the
biden administration's policy with
regards to cuban refugees which is quite
shocking and at odds with many other
things they've said about refugees from
other parts of the world
first let's talk about a great gift you
can get for yourself or for your parents
something really important so
out in your garage right now you got a
bunch of old memories and they're just
moldering right you've got a bunch of
pictures they're falling apart you got a
bunch of old video tapes you don't have
a vhs player anymore you got film reels
when's the last time you
took out a projector no one owns one
anymore you need to get all that stuff
digitized here is where legacy box
comes in legacy box is an effortless way
to have your outdated media digitally
preserved in a modern format
right now they are offering 40 off so
you can ensure your memories are safe
for generations
legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably digitally preserve your
past
the process from start finish is really
easy you pack you send their team
digitizes everything by hand
and then you enjoy get back perfectly
preserved digital copies on thumb drive
dvd or the cloud ready to watch
share and enjoy they thought of
everything they even provide
state-of-the-art tracking and send you
updates at every step of the process
send your precious recorded moments to a
company you can trust legacy box is the
world's largest digitizer of home movies
and photos they've helped more than a
million families preserve their past
including mine
i sent a bunch of stuff from my parents
house to them they digitized it all it's
fantastic my parents now have access to
all of
their childhood memories it's it's an
amazing thing right now legacy box is
offering 40
off so your family can celebrate those
meaningful moments at a fraction of the
normal price
visit legacybox.com shapiro to get
started today
that is legacybox.com slash apparel for
40 off legacybox.com
shapiro okay so meanwhile the biden
administration is making one thing very
clear
that if cubans attempt to float their
way off the island
they will be turned back and they will
be sent back to cuba now
the the biden administration has changed
its tune a little bit when it comes to
people coming to the united states
border right only in the past few weeks
have they started to say things like
don't don't show up at the southern
border but for months
the message was don't show up like right
now but if you do show up we're not
going to hold you in
a third-party country like mexico
remember they attempted to walk back the
trump agreement with the mexican
government that would allow people
applying for asylum
to be sheltered in mexico or to stay in
mexico while they apply for asylum
the bite administration wanted to walk
that back and allow people to come to
the united states and then essentially
be released into the interior
pending their asylum hearing the biden
administration made very clear
before biden even took office that they
were going to be very pro-open borders
they were not going to strictly enforce
immigration law
and that if you showed up at the border
that you would probably be released into
the interior
but when it comes to the cubans
different story you know people who seem
to have a pretty good asylum claim
and these are not folks who are fleeing
because they're they're
lacking a job these are not folks who
are fleeing because of economic
circumstance these are people who are
fleeing communist depression
so much so that they're not braving a
walk or a train ride or even
a uh coyote smuggling across the
american border they are literally
getting in boats
with leaks and attempting to float their
way via the tides to florida through
shark infested waters
and according to the bite administration
well now they're getting tough on
immigration weird how they get real
tough on immigration when it comes to
cuban populations presumably because
those cuban populations if they enter
the united states and receive asylum and
eventually become citizens are more
likely to vote republican
than people who are crossing the
southern border of the united states
that's the only logical reason i can
think of for the distinction between how
the biden administration
is treating in rhetoric cuban refugees
who are seeking asylum
and syrian refugees who saw asylum
during the trump administration or
honduran refugees who are seeking asylum
largely based on economic circumstance
during the during the trump and biden
administration here's jen saki being
very harsh with
with cubans who are attempting to flee
the way to come to the united states
is not uh through uh through uh
processes of trying to come to the
border uh that
without going through an asylum process
or coming by sea
uh without going through an asylum
application process
uh there are certainly uh programs uh
that through which that some of them
have been uh have not been reinstated
i should say uh that were in place put
in place by the
uh trump administration that are being
reviewed as he said yesterday
that would apply to uh the individuals
and people of haiti and the people
of cuba as well alejandro mayorkas is
the current head of the department of
homeland security
and who himself is a cuban refugee
immigrant
right his family at fled cuba when he
was a child
and he says same thing he says if you
get in a boat and you try to float your
way to cuba we're going to turn you back
and we'll probably send you back to cuba
allow me to be clear if you take
to the sea you will not come
to the united states the time is never
right
to attempt migration i see to those who
risk their lives
doing so this risk is not worth taking
again i repeat do not risk your life
attempting
to enter the united states illegally you
will not
come to the united states okay no uh i i
again i'm noticing a wide gap between
the level of rhetoric being used
currently with regard to cuban refugees
and the river accused say three months
ago with regard to people who are
attempting to cross the mexican border
illegally
a wide gap now i'm not even saying that
the policy of
having people held in third-party
countries while they
await asylum hearings for cuban refugees
for example
is wrong i'm not making a case for
wetfoot dry foot which was the policy
for many years in the united states
whereby if a cuban refugee set foot on
american land then they could
be granted asylum at least while they
were having their asylum claims
pending and if they were captured by
water like the coast guard picked them
off 10
10 feet off the shore then they were
immediately returned to their home
country
i'm not making the case that that should
be the policy the case that i am making
here
is not a policy one the point that i'm
making is that the the biden
administration seems a lot more troubled
by cuba
by cuban cuban refugees seeking a place
in the united states than they are by
people from nearly anywhere else and i
find that somewhat interesting
why why could it have to do with the
politics of the people fleeing
could it that's it on a policy level it
seems to me that if you're fleeing
communism the united states
should be a logical place for you to go
because you're coming from a country
that has in place ideas antithetical
to those of the united states founding
and we should welcome you with open arms
we need more people who hate communism
here in the united states we need
more people from hong kong who
understand the the evils of communism to
come to the united states and bring
their entrepreneurship
and bring their belief in individual
rights here to the united states we need
more people
from cuba who understand the evils of
communism in the united states
and i do think that we should take into
account the values of people who are
coming to the united states when we
determine if they should become american
citizens i don't think everybody has an
equal claim to be an american citizen
i think the administration feels the
same way i think that very often they
feel the same way
in reverse in just one second we'll get
to the
biden administration's policies with
regard to iran again it seems like the
the appeasement orientation
of this administration with regard to
foreign policy is quite obvious and it
is very
obama-esque never let reality get in the
way of your ideological commitment
to american appeasement and surrender if
you have to you know
make nice with the cuban dictatorship to
the point where you kind of
in wishy-washy fashion condemn what
they're doing but you won't condemn
communism then you do it
and if you continue to negotiate with
the iranian regime
which is a a fascistic theocracy
that oppresses its own people even while
the iranian regime is attempting to
kidnap american citizens
this be speaks an administration that is
not committed to american ideals it is
an administration
committed to certain appeasement
orientation
on the foreign stage we'll get some more
of that in just one moment first let us
talk about
a simple fact if you're going to the
post office you're spending too much
time at the post office you don't need
to go to the post office post office is
great but why would you want to wait in
line
schlep all your packages over there
where you can do everything you need to
do from your home or your office
with stamps.com you can skip trips to
the post office and save on postage
you can mail and ship anytime anywhere
right from your computer you can send
letters
ship packages and pay less a lot less
with discounted rates from usps and ups
stamps.com saves businesses thousands of
hours and tons of money every year
here at dailywire we've been using
stamps.com since 2017
no more wasting our time stamps.com
brings the same us postal and ups
shipping services directly to your
computer
they make it easy for small businesses
to mail and ship without needing to take
a trip to the post office in the first
place you can print official us postage
and shipping levels 24 7
without having to leave your desk or buy
any fancy equipment all you
need is your computer and a standard
printer and once your mail is ready just
schedule a pick up or a drop-off it is
indeed
that simple it's a no-brainer they've
saved nearly a million small business
owners like you
time and money and again you're going to
get up to 40 off usps up to 66
off ups shipping rates when you use
stamps.com stop wasting your time at the
post office go to stamps.com no risk
with my promo code shapiro you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office again
speaking of iran the iranian regime the
other day
attempted to kidnap an iranian-american
and
again remember when it was the saudis
doing this to
uh to jamal khashoggi a person who
had a visa in the united states this was
an international story they kidnapped
this guy and killed him khashoggi this
turned into an international relations
crisis
when the iranians attempt to kidnap an
iranian american the biden
administration basically just blows it
off
unsealed documents from federal court
have now charged for iranian
interoperable operatives for a
conspiracy to kidnap a woman named masih
ala nashad a human rights activist who
fled around in 2009 and is a critic of
the
nation's regime this is according to
mediaite jensaki
was was asked about all of this and she
condemned the iranian kidnapping plot
but
in in rather tepid terms
we categorically condemn iran's
dangerous and despicable reported plot
to kidnap a u.s citizen
on u.s soil we will forcefully defend
u.s citizens and u.s
interests that includes law enforcement
actions like the one announced
yesterday as well as the actions the
president has taken to defend
u.s forces in the region from
iranian-backed militant groups
it also includes our diplomatic effort
to constrain iran's nuclear program
one of our most important and urgent
actions
that's the part where it starts to get
tepid in the wild so yes we condemn it's
despicable it's terrible it's
also we need to make a deal we need to
cut a nuclear deal with the iranians
very important to cut that nuclear deal
you know just because they kidnap
american citizens we should definitely
make sure to relieve some sanctions on
them according to the washington free
beacon the state department informed
congress late on tuesday it would wave
sanctions on iran's illicit oil trade so
the country can access frozen funds from
south korea and japan that is the same
day the doj announced charges on an
iranian spy network that sought to
kidnap an american
the waiver signed by secretary of state
anthony blinken allows the
transfer of iranian funds in restricted
accounts to exporters in japan and the
republic of korea
according to a notification sent to
congress by the state department the
waiver allows iranian money
frozen as a result of american sanctions
to be freed up without violating the law
so good news the iranian administration
is uh trying to kidnap americans and
also
the biden administration is trying to
give the money and what
what a stalwart moderate administration
this is this iranian journalist then
came out and said um
guys you don't you know be great as if
you didn't appease the regime that just
tried to kidnap and kill me
i'm a little bit disappointed with
biden's administration because
i'm still waiting for them to take a
strong action when jamal khashoggi
this you know american saudi journalists
got brutally murdered the whole world
you know made statements of con
condemnations
i need the same because another regime
in the middle east the islamic republic
was trying to kidnap me so that is why i
want by the administration to be strong
instead of just going after them having
a deal with them
they have to care about human rights as
well
um yes but they don't but they don't
well the good news is you know speaking
of immigration you mentioned the the
cuban immigration policy that's being
put out by the bible administration
right now
nobody gets in right if you get on a
boat try to float your way on that 1955
chevy to the united states with your
children
intel if you do that we'll turn you back
meanwhile
the new democratic budget is going to
try to cram through an amnesty provision
truly it's an amazing thing they're
going to try and amnesty some 11 million
people who are living in the united
states illegally so the rule is that if
you're already here
and if you cross the southern border
generally or you're overstaying your
visa
we are going to make sure that we have
some sort of plan for you to become a
citizen if you
are trying to escape communist tyranny
in cuba then we're going to turn you
back
so the the democrats are attempting to
leverage this into a budget bill they
couldn't pass a separate immigration
bill
our government is completely
non-functional the bargain that was
created by the founding fathers with
regard to how legislation was supposed
to work is never pursued it is it just
does not exist anymore
so it used to be that schoolhouse rock
described how a bill was passed right it
was proposed in the house
and then it was passed by the senate and
then if there were disagreements between
the house and the senate bill there
would be a committee they would get
together they'd make some changes they'd
both vote on the bill again
and then it would go to the president
who would veto it and now
the way that but the way that bills
basically work is you put together a
million page bill that no one has ever
read and then you cram it through in the
dead of night with a straight party line
vote
and then the media demagogued the issue
by suggesting that anybody who is
against the bill was against every
element of the bill
and so we just end up with these crap
sandwiches and bills it's been a long
time since we have passed a single issue
bill that was not a giant crap sandwich
so democrats are trying to shove down
their latest craps and which this is a
3.5
trillion dollar budget bill this is
apart
from the quote unquote bipartisan 1.2
trillion dollar infrastructure bill
we'll get to that in a second
but this bill does include amnesty
provisions
it's an attempt to cram through amnesty
according to representative jayapal
who is the from washington from illegal
she said on wednesday that the 3.5
trillion budget proposal by democrats
will include a number of top liberal
priorities including
pathways to citizenship for millions of
illegal immigrants we're not going to
try to negotiate exactly how that works
and we're not going to shut the border
before we do that we're just going to
grant amnesty
now listen everybody in the united
states has a
here's the truth most americans are
pretty much on the same page when it
comes to legal immigration
close the border figure out what to do
with the people here
close the border is the first step of
that but you haven't closed the border
the border is wide open
we have more people being held in
containment facilities on the border
than any time during the trump
administration like right now
the border has been deemed wide open by
the bible administration lately
they are trying to pretend that they are
shutting the border they are not
and then they're just going to legalize
people who are already here illegally
thus spurring more illegal immigration
which of course is the entire point
and they're going to try and cram
through all of these illegal immigration
provisions in a budget bill
which again is not how this thing is
supposed to be done last i checked
immigration bills are supposed to be
about immigration
and budget bills are supposed to be
about the budget but because of
budget reconciliation processes you can
pass a a reconciliation bill
through 50 votes plus one in the senate
or 50 votes plus the vice president in
the senate
and then you don't have to worry about
the filibuster if this were just an
immigration bill it would undoubtedly be
filibustered
but because they're stuffing it into a
budget bill illegally i should add
they're going to try and get this
through with a simple party-line
majority vote so apparently the bill
would include provisions to allow
recipients of obama-era deferred action
for child to rival programs
full citizenship temporary protected
status recipients
would also be given a green card
basically it would include a pathway to
citizenship for dreamers tps essential
workers
and farm workers as well according to
fox news while the details are on clear
past efforts that such pathways for farm
workers
have been eligible for if they if they
have worked 400 days or more in a
five-year period
and passed background checks and
included seasonal or temporary work
democrats also want amnesty for
quote-unquote essential workers
they define this from broadly including
anyone who works in a sector like
healthcare emergency response sanitation
restaurant ownership
food preparation vending catering food
packaging meat processing hotel retail
work agricultural work landscaping
construction anti-services house
cleaning and janitorial services so
basically if you're in the united states
working illegally
we should give you a a visa we should
give you a green card and a path toward
citizenship
and they're going to try and cram this
through in a budget bill okay in the
dead of night
via reconciliation it's illegal by the
way again i'll explain that in a second
they're not allowed to do this they're
gonna try it anyway we'll get some more
of this in just one second first
if you've been listening to the show for
a while you've probably heard me talk
about my helix sleep mattress
well now helix has launched a new
company it's called all form they're
making premium customizable sofas and
chairs
shipped directly to your door so what
makes an all form sofa really awesome
well for starters it's the easiest way
you can customize the sofa using premium
materials
and at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you can pick your
fabric it is spill stain scratch
resistant
the sofa color the color of the legs
sofa size and shape
make sure it is perfect for you and your
home you've got arm chairs and love
seats all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone
and you can always start small and buy
more seats later on if you want your all
form sofa to grow and change with you
when you move all form sofas are also
delivered directly to your door in the
past
if you wanted to order a sofa you need
to hire somebody to come and assemble it
for you not so with all form to make it
quick and easy
i do indeed have an all-form sofa last
night my wife was
using the bedroom to pack up for a trip
that we were going on
and um that meant i could not sleep on
my bed for a little while so i was
napping on her all for himself let me
tell you that thing is just unbelievably
comfortable
we have the three seed sofa with the
cheese in the sand color with espresso
legs if getting a sofa without trying it
in store sounds a little risky you don't
need to worry you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it that's more than
three months
if you don't love it they'll pick it up
for free and give you a full refund they
also have a forever warranty like
literally
for all times to find your perfect sofa
check out allform.com
slash ben and all form is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners
at allform.com that is a solid deal on
an excellent couch go check them out
allform.com ben alrighty so
democrats again they're trying to push
forward this amnesty package
they don't really have the legal ability
to use some of that that probably won't
stop them christopher jacobs is a good
piece over at the federalist about this
he points out that reconciliation
typically requires certain things to be
fulfilled in order to be included
in a reconciliation bill you can't just
slap together any old thing and then say
budget reconciliation applies it's a
very specific procedure
for things that are supposed to be
budgetarily neutral
and well as as jacobs point out
democrats want to use reconciliation
to ram through priorities through the
senate on a party-line vote but that
process includes procedural strictures
including a six-part test called the
bird rule designed to preserve the
integrity of the legislative filibuster
because remember
basically what budget reconciliation is
it's a way to pass budgets
even though there's an attempt to
filibuster that rule named for
former senate majority leader robert
byrd prohibits the inclusion of
extraneous material
absent the agreement of 60 senators to
waive senate rules and keep the material
on the bill
one of the tests under the bird rule
applies to a provision that quote
produces changes in outlays or revenues
which are merely incidental to the
non-budgetary components of the
provision
this test for example tripped up the
minimum wage increase democrats wanted
to add to their coveted relief bill
earlier this year says jacob's
immigration replicates the minimum wage
debate
in february the cbo concluded raising
the minimum wage to 15 bucks an hour
would have sizable budgetary effects
cbo estimated such an increase would
generate a total of 19.7 billion dollars
in net tax revenue
over 10 years it would also increase the
deficit by 54 billion
over the same period of time cbo
concluded a minimum wage increase would
raise wages by a net of 333 billion
over 10 years which was a lot higher
than the 19.7 billion
in net revenue the federal government
would receive so it really wasn't a
budgetary proposal
it had to do with just general policy
he says they would have a jacob says
changes to immigration laws are sort of
similar they have a budgetary impact but
regardless of whether you believe
these would increase or decrease the
federal deficit they have far larger
changes on the economy and the country
as a whole
so they probably fall fell of the bird
rule test so it's not even clear
that you can cram immigration into the
budget but that's not going to try to
democrats are going to try it anyway now
it's pretty unpopular is the reality
according to the washington examiner new
polling data
suggests that most americans are not
particularly happy with the way that joe
biden has been handling the border
democrats however need to cram this
through remember for democrat it is
all about world breaking change and
doing it fast
and doing it quickly and making sure
that you can get more democratic voters
in the polls as fast as humanly possible
again i think that it is very difficult
to to miss
the level of discrepancy between how
democrats are treating republican
refugees
or presumed possible republican refugees
from cuba and how they're treating
the illegal immigrants who are currently
here who they presume will vote democrat
i i don't think the democrats are
completely unaware of the political
consequences
of what they're doing right here okay
but
it's not just a matter of amnesty
they're also pushing for it as we say a
3.5 trillion
budget reconciliation bill now you may
have noticed we have a serious inflation
problem
in the country right now we are seeing
prices spiking dramatically year over
year
perhaps that peter's out perhaps it
doesn't you know it's a bad idea
blowing trillions of new spending into
the economy
i mean joe biden has proposed something
like 12 trillion dollars of new spending
already this year
we spent seven trillion dollars last
year we've already spent
two trillion dollars on one of joe
biden's plans he wants to also pass this
american jobs and family plan which is
another two trillion dollars he wants to
pass a 1.2 trillion dollar quote-unquote
infrastructure plan
and then he also wants to pass the 3.5
trillion dollar budget
that's a lot of money to blow into the
american economy as inflation
rises so democrats want a 3.5
trillion dollar budget president biden
says we're gonna get a lot done
that's what he says not only that by the
way he says we have to have two tracks
here's where the republicans need to
stop being dum-dums so i pointed out
earlier that you have these republicans
like mitt romney we're trying to cut a
bipartisan deal with joe manchin
and kristen cinema with regard to
infrastructure right they cut down the
bill from like two trillion dollars to
1.2 trillion
ah bipartisanship yay but joe biden had
said pretty clearly
we are going to simply take all the
spending we can't do there and we're
going to ram it through reconciliation
so why are you giving him
the veneer of bipartisanship why
and what if if the idea here is that you
are dealing with the democrats to reduce
the spending then if democrats say oh
yes simultaneously we on a party-line
vote are also going to cram through the
spending
with this hand while we do the
bipartisan thing with this hand well
then why would you give them the
bipartisan thing it makes no sense at
all and joe biden is not hiding the ball
here
he's made very clear that he wants a
quote unquote two-track process
whereby he gets republican help to pass
a 1.2 trillion dollar boondoggle
most of it is boondoggle and at the same
time he wants to
ram through with 50 votes including
cinema
and and mansion this 3.5 trillion dollar
budget proposal
that's 4.7 trillion dollars in new
spending after spending 2 trillion
already this year and that ain't gonna
be the end of it here's joe biden
openly saying that he is lying to
republicans and that the entire goal
here
is to basically inflate the
reconciliation balloon
if the bipartisan balloon gets a little
bit deflated in terms of the amount of
spending
we have an agreement we have an
agreement there may be slate changes
i'm not sure what may happen exactly how
but it's going to be paid for and
that's we're going to do so thank you
all very much mr president any concern
that having
two tracks here well disrupted by person
no i think it's the only way to get it
done
he's openly saying what he is doing so
if you are senator romney
or if you are senator portman or if
you're any of the other senators on the
republican side of the aisle who are
providing cover to these shenanigans
don't be an idiot what are you doing
what are you doing
why are you giving him the patina of
bipartisanship when he is openly stating
that he is going to stab you directly
between the shoulder blades unless you
have tremendous levels of trust from joe
manchin and christian cinema that they
kill the 3.5 trillion
budget plan because they prefer the
bipartisan plan
then you need to withdraw okay and we
need like open assurances from mansion
and cinema right now that they're not
going to vote for this 3.5 trillion
bill that is an attempt also to cram
through amnesty at the same exact time
now it's unclear where mansion and
cinema are going to come down on this
apparently mansion supports
the immigration provisions of the budget
reconciliation bill
which is unbelievable again if that
happens then then
obviously there are no provisions for
recall in of senators obviously
in places like west virginia but uh next
time he's up for election uh he's gonna
be in serious trouble in west virginia
if he continues to push forward amnesty
in any sort of budget reconciliation
plan
but manchin is not made clear exactly
where he stands on all this he says i
know my democratic colleagues on the
budget committee have worked hard i look
forward to reviewing their agreement
i'm also very interested in how this
proposal is paid for and how it enables
us to remain globally competitive
i will reserve any final judgment until
i've had the opportunity to thoroughly
evaluate the proposal so
it sounds like he is at least a little
bit skeptical of the 3.5 trillion dollar
budget plan
again they're doing all of this in an
inflationary spiral fed chair jerome
powell admitted yesterday that the
inflation has been much higher than
expected in recent months
the incoming inflation data have been
higher than expected and hoped for
but they're actually still consistent
with with what we've been talking about
that the
the very high inflation readings are
coming from a small group
of goods and services that are directly
tied to the reopening of the economy
it's it's
new new cars used cars rental cars hotel
rooms
air you know airplane tickets things
that we understand
and by the way this just demonstrates
the federal reserve has no intention
of slowing the the vast inflation that
they are inflicting on the economy right
now
and by the way even if they slow the
inflation the amount of government
spending and regulation and taxation
that's about to be put on the economy is
going to sink
the the record american growth rates we
are currently seeing down to
one percent within two years that that
is basically according to the biden
administration's own estimates at this
point
all right in just one second we'll get
to the biden administration
pushing forward the idea once more that
we are in some sort of civil
war we'll get to that in just a second
first as you may have noticed the art
market is absolutely booming
right now deloitte reports the overall
art market is expected to grow by over
900 billion dollars by 2026
but very few people know about that
asset class i mean millionaires hedge
funds they're pouring money into art
because it's actually a pretty good
holder of value
i recently found a little known but
incredibly smart way for everyday
investors to diversify in fine art
without breaking the bank
masterworks dot io the premium
membership for
investing in contemporary art from 95
through 2020 contemporary art prices
outpaced s
p 500 returns by 174 percent that is a
very large difference even in a bull
market
thanks to masterworks dot io you can
invest in multi-million dollar works by
artists like picasso
warhol and even banksy with the
government handing out trillions of
bucks inflation is rising it's up 5.4
in june it's the most since 2008 a good
way of hedging against inflation
you seek out tangible assets whether
you're talking about real estate or gold
or art to protect your portfolio there's
a reason 86
of wealth managers recommend investing
in art and collectibles
as well listeners of this show can skip
the waitlist at masterworks dot io
slash ben see disclosures at
masterworks.io disclaimer you can't
afford a picasso you can't afford a part
of a picasso however visit masterworks
dot io
ben today all right we'll get to more of
this in just
one second first as totalitarian
lockdowns rage on across
the world in places like california
creeped for reinstating mass mandates it
is not difficult to see that we are
living through a rather authoritarian
time and this is true of
all of our major institutions whether
we're talking about amazon
banning books or whether we are talking
about your local corporation deciding
what you must
think and what black square you must
post it today
we are all under the gun it feels like
that and the institutions have been
weaponized against us this is why i
wrote my new book the authoritarian
moment to explain how all of our
institutions have been renormalized and
weaponized and what we can do to fight
back
because we can we can take back these
institutions but you have to know how
that's what the authoritarian moment
is about the authoritarian moment is all
about how our institutions not even the
government
most of the institutions of power even
outside the government have been
weaponized
in on behalf of a militant leftist
ideology but here's the thing it is a
small group of people who are doing this
and we can push back and we can win the
authoritarian moment is now available
for pre-order
at amazon barnes and noble or any other
major book seller so go
get your copy right now also you may
have noticed that candice owens may be
limited to a certain number of
characters on twitter but you don't have
to worry she has an entire show here at
the daily wire called candace it is full
of her uncensored opinions without any
limits her latest episode cuba communism
and the democratic death cult
is available right now on demand for
daily war members if you haven't yet
subscribed to get 25
off a new membership with code candace
you are listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so the democratic party the biden
administration
they're not stopping with budget
reconciliation they're also of course
pushing for this
terrible for the people act which
completely rewrites the bargain
between the states and the federal
government with regard to voting
procedure the democrats continue to
foster the lie and it is an absolute
dangerous lie and it is a lie that is
going to lead to actual conflict
and maybe violence okay this lie is that
half of americans are seeking to return
to jim crow
half americans are brutal vicious racist
are seeking to return
to a horrible time of racial oppression
and
so in support of this lie texas
democratic legislators absconded they
left the state of texas
and they fled to their their favorite
people in washington dc
they they fled over to the warm cuddly
blanket of washington dc
where they were welcomed with open arms
by the white house
now remember this is not anti-democratic
it's not anti-democratic for a party
in the minority to flee in order to deny
quorum it's anti-democratic
for a party to vote in the majority in
texas for voter id that's
anti-democratic according to the
democrats
you may have noticed the word democratic
doesn't actually mean a majority
votes in this particular scenario just
means democrats don't get what they want
in any case jensaki was out there
defending these texas democratic
legislators yesterday because
after all no biggie when when you flee a
state
in order to avoid losing that that is
not anti-democratic
that is brave the vice president uh met
with these legislators yesterday
uh and the vice president and the
president i should say certainly
applauds uh their actions and their
outspoken
opposition to states uh to efforts to
put in place restrictive measures in
their state
and maybe it is funny to think about it
that way but the president
is talking about this as the most
serious assault on i don't know i don't
think anything about
i don't think anything about this is
funny
funny well i mean it's a little funny
they showed up in washington dc they eat
caesar salads they talk about how brave
they are and they think we shall
overcome
while they are being massaged by kamala
harris it's a little funny
and the notion these are brave freedom
fighters is entirely absurd
on his face nonetheless that is how the
the most awkward and fake politician of
the modern era kamala harris put it
yesterday
uh she she defended the texas
legislators and compared them to
frederick douglass
because they're just like a freed slave
who spends his life going around
trying to teach others about the evils
of slave they're just like that
except for how they're not like that in
any possible way here is kamala harris
being awful
they took bold courageous action
in line with the legacy of everyone from
frederick douglass who's over my right
shoulder
when he fought for the right of black
men to vote in america
to the legacy that includes all those
women who marched down pennsylvania
avenue
for women's right to vote to all of
those folks who shed their blood on the
edmund pettus bridge
to make sure that we would in 1965 pass
the voting rights act
um no that that is no that is not
remotely correct but
one of the democratic attempts here is
to rewrite america's history so number
one it is way worse than it is right
america's history has enough dark spots
you don't have to make america's
entire history the history of all racism
in the universe
and root all of america's institutions
in it that's one thing democrats are
trying to do and then
they're trying to make the secondary
move which is to say that today's
republicans are defenders of that
history
and want to return to that history
there's a reason why she's comparing
this to the edmund pettus bridge
because the suggestion of course i mean
joe biden is saying it openly is that
today's republicans are exactly the same
as people who are using fire hoses on
martin luther king
right that is exactly what she is
suggesting and some people like charles
blow
say the same thing fairly openly charles
blow of the new york times again one of
the
lesser lights over at the new york times
op-ed page he has a piece today
titled welcome to jim crow 2.0 now again
you may be asking yourself
wait a second this doesn't look anything
like jim crow like i've noticed that
this doesn't look
literally anything like jim crow that
black people are voting in record
numbers black people are being elected
in record numbers we've had a black
president twice
many of the most powerful powerful
people in our society are black we have
an entire
country that mobilized to post black
squares on their facebook page based on
the lie
that america's police are targeting
black people which is not statistically
true
okay and and yet this is like jim crow
2.0 according to charles blow it is
according to charles blow it's exactly
like 1890.
nothing has changed and this is the game
that people on the left are constantly
playing
the evils of the past are are here they
are just more subtle
in american society today they've just
gone underground but
you can spot the signs and the signs are
people wearing red hat
and the signs are people voting
republican and the signs are people
supporting voter id
and the signs are people supporting
voter integrity
and so there's only one choice trillions
of dollars in spending
amnesty and budget reconciliation bills
a federalization of all voting
procedures
and give us what we want because our
enemies are hitler and that is
it's an immature push by the democrats
but it may be all they have left
considering that their agenda is wildly
unpopular
alrighty we will be back here later
today with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show coming up soon as the matt
wall show airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pablo wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike caromina here and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show